CAT: I'm Cat and I'm a member
of the Authors at Google Team.
It's truly a pleasure for
me to welcome chef Roy Choi
and introduce his new book
"L.A. Son" at Google L.A. today.
Back in early 2009, Kogi was the
first food truck to visit us.
And I remember we had a long
line of Googlers stretching
around the block all eager
to try Roy's delicious food.
Roy was born Korean but
raised in Los Angeles
since he was two years old.
He graduated from the
Culinary Institute of America.
After several years of
cooking in New York, Tokyo,
and throughout California,
Roy started Kogi
and started three
different restaurants
in L.A. with a fourth one
coming soon to Korea Town.
Now please help me
welcome Roy Choi.
ROY CHOI: Thank you.
And that's "L.A. Son."
We're done.
That's my whole life
story right there.
It's good to be here, man.
I know this area really well.
I hang out in Venice, got
restaurants in Venice.
I was looking at opening a
spot right next door here
on Sunset and Fourth.
I heard the rumor you guys
don't leave this building.
That's what the outside
world thinks of you.
It's like you guys
are trapped here.
But yeah, over there, but
it just didn't work out.
I was going to open this
spot with my friend,
like a breakfast spot.
But we're still
looking for a location,
so if you think it's
good, then maybe.
Kogi has been an amazing
thing in my life.
In our whole team--
in a way it maybe
mirrors a lot of things that
you guys may experience,
not on food level but as far
as puncturing the atmosphere
or puncturing universe
with maybe your thoughts
and your engineering
innovations and with startups.
We were part of a wave
and we hit a nerve.
It was digital, but instead
of it just being digital,
it was also human, as well.
It became something that really
just affected people and made
smart people dumb and
dumb people smart.
I don't know, it's crazy.
But this book that we're
going to talk about today
is not the Kogi book.
It's strange that I didn't write
the Kogi book because like it's
like having a race car
but never driving it.
It was most expected thing
to just go ahead and write
the Kogi book, but
I don't like doing
things that aren't
ready to do it yet.
I don't like doing things
that are forced just
for the sake of
commerce or attention.
So like, to me the Kogi
book isn't ready yet.
We're still out there.
After I'm done talking to
you, you're going to eat Kogi.
We're still in the moment.
We're still figuring
our own story out.
I had to figure out-- to
confront the issue of actually
writing a book
itself, because-- I
guess I can backtrack
a little bit.
I don't know if I'm telling
you this for empathy
or to try to explain
this book, but I never
wanted to write a book, ever.
To me it seemed kind of douchey
to write a book about yourself.
It's like, what the fuck.
Sometimes you wake up and you
can't architect or imagine
things or moments where
people want things--
I grew up in an
environment in my life
where not many people
wanted things from me.
And then usually, I created
a little bit of a force field
around myself.
She told me you guys don't talk
to each other when you work.
So kind of like that.
I created a force
field around myself
where even if you did
want something from me,
I really didn't want to
explain it or give it to you.
But then after the first couple
of years of Kogi, what happened
was things started to
unravel in that force field.
Instead of me always raising
an eyebrow of suspicion,
I allowed these questions
to come through.
And they start
coming tenfold where
people were asking
the same question of,
how did you come
up with this food?
Tell me everything
about this food.
I can't stop eating it.
Why did you cook it?
Where did you come
up with the flavor?
I need to know right now.
And these were people I just
met grabbing me by the lapels.
And so I decided
maybe it's time to not
react the same way that
I've done my whole life.
Maybe these are signals from
somewhere for me to look at it.
Maybe it's not
just about myself.
Maybe the way this food has
affected yourselves and others
and why you're raising
these questions
to a complete
stranger, maybe it's
a gateway or a little
clue into something
that I should explore.
And that was kind of the thing
that pushed me over the hump.
Because I'm a really shy dude.
I was not ever prepared or
read to sit in this chair
and speak to you about
a book about my life.
But once I had confronted
that, I woke up.
And sometimes you wake up and
you realize that-- you just
know something, and
you just realize it.
You'll read
throughout this book,
there are those moments
that had I've had.
And I realized
that this was just
another succession
of those moments.
I was a deadbeat.
And then I woke up
on a couch and I
realized that I had to cook,
and then I just started cooking.
It was kind of the same I
guess epiphany with this book,
was I was fighting
it for so long.
Any of you true
OG Kogi followers,
like from the beginning?
OK.
I was pretty hardcore
at the beginning.
When I was cooking,
I had like sonars.
If you talked any
shit about the food,
I would come outside, pull
that shit out your hand,
close the doors, and take off.
I was not in a place to write a
book to share things with you.
I just felt like I could
share this food with you,
and that's it.
But I woke up and I was
like, you know what?
Maybe I shouldn't be
so angry about things.
Maybe I can confront
these things with a smile
and actually look and
go down this road.
So once I woke up with that, I
called the two co-authors, Tim
and Natasha, and we met.
Do you have those moments
where you can see everything
almost in a parallel
universe, where it already
exists in full form, and
it's almost like you just
have to go to that
place in order
to populate it in
and bring it to life?
That's how this book was.
We called them.
We met on Pico and
Union at Lucy's.
Lucy's drive-in, like
Mexican American Cafe.
Beautiful place.
Outdoors, brick building, adobe
style, with benches out front.
You get the wind, a little bit
of the wind from the downtown
buildings, and also the sun
from setting here in Venice.
And I just sat there on
a piece of scratch paper
and the whole book as you see
it now was kind of laid out.
And it was our job to
fill in those spaces.
When I look back, is
the exact same book
that we saw just on
that scribble page.
So that was how we started
this process for the book.
But the book itself
is not a chef book,
let me start off with that.
It's not a chef book.
It's not a how to start
a food truck book.
Is not the secrets
of a restaurant book.
It's really a book about
a confused kid trying
to figure out his place in
worlds in which nothing ever
fit.
And it's a book about struggle.
book I think it speaks to
immigration, addiction.
I think it speaks
to a lot of issues
of being outcast and
also just compulsion.
Also just not really
finding a voice,
and then finding maybe
vices or just destructive
elements to fill in those
voids in order to continue on.
You guys are smart, so
I know you never really
had those struggles, probably.
Maybe you do, I don't know.
But I've never fit into the
fucking regular shit, man.
And so for me, as you go
through the chapters--
my parents were immigrants.
They were very educated
people, but they got to America
in the early '70s--
any family that
is an immigrant-- it's hard to
explain in a general context.
You have to go through it.
But this book is a step to
try to find that bridge.
When you use the
word racism, it's
hard to understand
that context of racism
from when the racism
is coming at you.
If you try to speak about
the nuances of what it feels
like to be ostracized
or not being
able to get a job in a
country that you moved to,
in a place where it's
not your first language
and where you look
different, it's very hard
to explain those
nuances and to explain
that pain and that struggle
and that confusion.
And then also to explain the
transgression and the evolution
of a human spirit and a soul
that is under that pressure,
almost like geothermal pressure.
It changes a person.
For my family, it
changed my parents.
It changed them into alcoholics.
It changed them
into people that put
their hopes and their
dreams in their children,
but also lived within the vortex
of losing their own dreams
and hopes.
And then for me, it
travels through that,
and it travels
through myself, going
through a lot different
neighborhoods.
And then really
trying to figure out
for a lot of immigrants kids,
especially from my generation,
and especially a lot of
Asian-American kids--
I know a Latino kids may go
through, it as well-- but just
living in this weird,
kind of suspended state
where you live double lives.
Food wasn't that big in our
society like 20, 30 years ago.
Not everybody was into kimchi
and fish guts and things
like that.
So in many ways, the
foods that we grow up on
were kind of hidden
and were labeled
stinky and disgusting and ugly.
I know a lot of Asian
kids will relate to this,
and a lot of Indian
kids will relate.
So we go through
that in this book
of just trying to explore that.
Not trying to make a
social commentary on it,
but just telling
you the real deal
of what it felt like to not show
your friends your refrigerator.
Or when you showed your
friends your refrigerator,
what the reactions were like.
How you want to just fight it,
but also you embarrassed by it.
You couldn't find the
words to explain it.
But then at the same
time, you loved it,
and this is the
food you grew up on.
It also talks about the culture
of L.A. I tried to really write
about three to four
decades of Los Angeles
and really let the pages
breathe L.A. all the way,
from the '70s and "Happy
Days," and the Dodgers,
and chili dogs, and
Eastside, and Legion Park,
all the way through
Korea Town into the '80s
and then through high school.
And then it gets into the '90s.
The book, even though it
travels in a linear form,
we tried to write
it in a way where,
almost like a movie, where
you could suspend your belief
and it could travel and
it goes into folklore
thousands of years
ago but also speaks
on what's going on at that time.
And then it reaches
a point-- and we
write about three really
strong addictions,
which is gambling,
alcohol, and then drugs.
And then at the end of
it, we find the food.
And then through the food, we
take you to different lands.
We take you to Japan.
I had the fortunate ability
to work in Japan for awhile.
And then it goes through
my career a little bit.
I'm really proud
of this book, man.
Every single corner of it.
The story, the recipes.
I wanted to write a
book, also, where--
I'll read a little
quick chapter for you.
But there was like
three or four things
we really wanted from this book.
And do you ever
have those moments
where you want something
and you create it?
And it maybe it doesn't come
out exactly the same way
as you imagined it, but
when you complete it,
it fulfilled the criteria,
but it also went beyond it?
Like, when we started
this book, one,
I wanted it to be affordable.
So the big goal was
to keep it under $30,
and we achieved that, even
with all the content in here.
Another thing was anyone
who read this book,
I wanted it to feel
like Los Angeles.
like the living
rooms of immigrant children
that grew up in Los Angeles.
The cardboard boxes,
the mix-match furniture,
the smells, everything.
The language, the
noise, everything.
And it does, I think.
When you flip through it,
it feels like Los Angeles.
And then I wanted,
also, the book
to read in a very infectious way
to where once you started it,
it sucked you in.
Because I always
considered this book
to be more than just a cookbook.
And that's why we went
with Anthony Bourdain
as a publisher.
For me, growing up, I didn't
have many people to relate
to as far as like--
when I read the classics
throughout high
school and stuff,
I could understand and
relate to whether it's
Chaucer or Fitzgerald or
Hemingway or whoever it is,
but I didn't live that life.
Even though intellectually
I could relate,
and from an imagination
standpoint I could relate,
but I never could relate
as far as understanding
the little nuances or
the traditions and stuff.
So I wanted to write a book
where there's a lot of kids
out there that are going through
it, that they could relate.
And not just immigration,
but also people going through
addictions right now.
We don't talk about
it a lot in society,
but people are
going through stuff.
A lot of my friends,
they don't read.
A lot of people, since
the book has come out,
I get texts and friends come
up to me, and they're like yo,
man, I haven't read a book in
like fucking 15 years, man.
I just finished your book,
and they're like, thank you.
And so like that was a big goal.
And then on the same topic
of reading, a lot of people
don't cook in their life.
And so we wanted
to create recipes
where after you read the
chapter, the recipes,
you could approach them and not
only theoretically make them,
but you would make
them, they would
become a part of your life.
And so there was no
showboating here.
I just flipped to
this right now,
but the ghetto Pillsbury
donuts are a perfect example.
Just creating recipe
that are gateways.
This is literally, you go
and get Pillsbury dough
and you put it in hot oil.
That's all you do.
But there's a lot
of tongue in cheek.
There's a lot of playing around.
What it is it's a gateway.
Because if you do
this, all you're doing
is putting dough
inside fried oil.
But if you do it,
what happens is one,
you yield a beautiful,
delicious product.
And then secondly,
what happens is
you're actually learning
about cooking technique
without it feeling
like you're learning,
or feeling like it's a lecture.
You're actually
having fun with it.
So that's what a lot of
these recipes are about.
But just to end this
real quick, I'll
read you a little excerpt
of the chapter that
actually got us the deal.
This chapter is called
"You Very Lucky Man."
And this deals with
a period of my life
in my early '20s when I
got addicted to gambling.
We have car clubs here
in Los Angeles-- Commerce
Club, Bicycle Club, used
to be Normandy Club,
it's now the Hustler.
Yeah, it's not like
Vegas in these clubs.
They're like quicksand
and black holes.
Once you enter these worlds, is
really, really hard to escape.
So it starts off,
"You very lucky, man.
I didn't mean to get
into gambling, I swear.
I told you, he's the best.
By the time I got
back from New York,
it was the end of January 1991.
I had nowhere to go other
than back to school.
So there I was, a 21-year-old
junior majoring in philosophy
and studying logic.
I figured I'd try to stay
clean, now hit the books,
get it right.
But try as I might, school
was as boring as shit,
and my mind started to wander.
I looked up some guys I
knew from high school who
were studying at
UCLA and ended up
moving in with the
Korean kid I met back
in honors English, Paul.
Week after week, we wasted
time playing video games,
trying to get laid, partying
hard, drinking harder.
Then he and his crew
started to hit the casinos.
At first I was just
going along for the ride.
Home run, all the way!"
These quotes are like what
they say at the casinos.
When you went in,
they were always
patting you on the
back and stuff.
"Home run, all the way.
But the instant I sat down at
the table and felt the felt,
I was jolted out of my routine.
Everything suddenly
became new, alive, fresh.
I could smoke, drink, watch
sports, gamble, talk shit,
make friends, flirt and eat.
Time didn't exist.
Neither did judgments.
Only possibilities and action.
The amenities just
made it sweeter.
Pats on the back, massages,
cheers, ladies, and the food.
Oh man, and the
motherfucking food, man.
The 710 freeway
runs north to south
along the eastern
outskirts of Los Angeles,
connecting the
San Gabriel Valley
to the ports of Long Beach.
The Bicycle Club-- or,
as we like to call it,
The Bike-- is
located off the 710
in the industrial section
of South Los Angeles.
On the way there
from almost anywhere
in L.A., Orange County,
or the Inland Empire,
you drive past South Gate,
Huntington Park, Vernon,
Cudahy, Paramount,
Gardena, Commerce, Bell
Gardens, and Bell-- places
that were cattle ranches
and farmland before they
morphed into lower-middle class
towns submerged
in smog and dust,
dominated by raw
industry-- meat packing,
smelt, metal, rubber,
food processing.
The Florence avenue exit
takes you off the 710 almost
directly to The Bike.
The lights flash on the sign
like any one of the oozing neon
signs lining the
Las Vegas strip.
There are three entrances to
The Bike-- two in the front,
one in the back.
It should be easy to just
walk in the goddamn building,
but when you've gambled so
much that it affects you mind,
body, and soul, everything
feels like Monty Hall asking you
for a door number.
I choose a door based on what
the spirits or glow of luck
dictated.
Some days, I knew
the big deal was
hidden behind door number three.
Other days, store number one
pulled me in like a vacuum.
No matter the
door, you instantly
feel the sense of place
the minute you enter.
The beetle-black heads of
Chinese, Koreans, Vietnamese,
Mexicans, and Armenians crowded
the tables-- populations that
have both ready
access to the 710
and a penchant for the casino's
Asian Pan Nine and Pai Gow
games.
There are some old timers, a
handful of fresh new faces,
college kids, and
blue-collar workers.
There are hangers on,
trolls with sunken eyes
and furrowed brows who stand
behind rails overlooking
the tables.
They throw out sycophantic
words of encouragement
in hopes of catching
crummy tips.
Rail birds squawking
at the action.
There's a pulsating white noise
of murmuring chatter, chips
clicking and clacking,
the squeaking wheels
of the candy girls' carts
rolling from one player
to another.
The place is huge and separated
into three major rooms.
The poker room and Asian games
room flank the Dragon room.
This room is the home of
the big city gangsters.
The Hong Kong and
Vegas big shots
were the lucky bastards who
won temporary riches elsewhere
in the casino and decided to
swim here with the sharks.
When I first started, you could
have found me day after day,
night after night, in
the Asian games room.
At ease amongst
residents who many
may refer to as social
deviants-- prostitutes, drug
addicts, delinquents, criminals,
gypsies, carnies, bums,
drunks sat in those
chairs, congregated
around those tables,
touched those cards.
Say what you will and
make your judgments,
but understand that there, even
in the underbelly of the city,
the ethics of the game-- the
challenge-- reign supreme.
You could leave $150,000
in chips on a card table,
walk away, take a
piss, and come back
to find your money
untouched, as if it
had been insured by the FDIC.
Try doing that a Google party.
On my first day at The
Bike, I started with $150.
The game was Pan Nine.
Ten players are at the
table, each with the goal
to beat the dealer
at his own game.
Each player gets three cards,
with one more optional.
The object is to add up
the value of the cards
and get the sum of nine.
Face cards are worth zero.
If you're Vietnamese and you
see a face card, all you say is,
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE], which
loosely translates as, fuck me.
I won.
I won again and again.
And I was on the street
fresh out of the gate.
I turned that 150 to
500 in 10 minutes.
I went from small $100
hands to huge $10,000 hands
and never looked back.
I should've looked back.
I should have reaped
my rewards and left
behind that room filled with
the hollow eyes and big nostrils
of Southeast Asia.
But I didn't.
Fuck the odds, I thought.
Fuck fate.
I was doomed from the start.
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]"
So from here, that was like our
splash into our sample chapter.
And then from here,
it really takes you
through the food of the casinos,
then through the addiction,
then through the fall,
and then where I end up
is basically I lost everything,
burned every bridge,
and then I was down at the end.
And the book is also
about certain saviors.
Like, my parents were there.
And then my friends
and my family
pulled me out of the casino.
It's a pretty heavy
book, so don't we
read it to your kids
at night unless they're
going through some shit.
And it ends right when
the Kogi truck starts.
That's pretty much "L.A. Son."
I'm proud of what it's done
so far in the first month.
It just came out in the
beginning of November.
I'm really proud of what it's
done for the first month.
It's really put a voice
out there for the city
and also for the struggle.
I think it inspired not only
people who are reading it,
but inspired our
publishers, as well,
to get behind a book that
was a little unconventional.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you know what
you said [INAUDIBLE] talk?
[INAUDIBLE] your
thoughts on where
you see food going in terms
of accessibility [INAUDIBLE]
in the next 10, 15 years,
where you see yourself in that?
[INAUDIBLE].
ROY CHOI: I think it's
first-- for the evolution
in the development of food, I
think one of the first steps
as we have to have open
conversations about it.
That was the biggest
kind of hurdle and thing
I was thinking about
right before I went out
to Copenhagen, was I didn't know
how the chef community would
react to the speech.
But I just knew I
had to tell them.
I didn't really care whether
or exiled me or not afterwards.
But I think first,
just talking about it.
For me, I'm only one person.
I would love to continue
to stay involved.
I think where I want to move in
the next five to 10 years is,
instead of it just being a
physical thing for me where I'm
actually out there just
hand-to-mouth feeding people,
which I'll always do, sparking
smart people like yourself
for us to collectively
not only talk about it,
but come up with systems
and new processes
to figure these things out.
Combine technology.
Combine engineering.
New modules and serving
systems and thoroughfare
some pathways to actually
feed communities.
Not thinking that
everything has to be
exactly the way we
currently eat right now.
So that's really what I see.
I think it's taking
vacant lots, creating
the kind of like Hawker Centres.
Creating outdoor eating
environments for us
to congregate and eat.
Maybe almost creating
shells, almost like library
cubicles, or whatever.
Or almost like co-op shells.
You guys at Google
can design them.
Really, really cool shit.
Where you can go in and then
develop concepts, or try out
concepts of food.
The main thing is,
we have to make food
a part of the culture.
I think another angle
that you guys can really
help-- especially
not just Google,
but your guys' world--
is through our messaging
and our media and
advertising and corporations.
Making food a part
of pop culture.
Because the thing about the
accessibility and the landscape
of food and the disparities
is it's not just about money.
It's about messaging and
importance and culture.
Because even though
there are neighborhoods
that don't have that
much money, there's
still enough money to buy junk.
There's still enough money
to buy sodas and junk
and also phones and products
that you guys are creating.
There's still money to buy that.
So it's really maybe just
taking some of our energy
and focusing some of our
skills on making food
a part of that conversation.
So I'd like to get
involved with that.
I want to use whatever resources
I have-- ground level and also
top scale.
Musicians, artists.
Use my agency.
Use foundations.
Try to create a
full 360 map for it.
I think it's going to
take at least-- Matt,
I mentioned the five year cycle
because I lived through it.
I'm not an intellectual,
but I can only
tell you from
first-hand experience,
I saw a whole world change in
front of my eyes in five years.
A lot of you guys weren't eating
off trucks five years ago,
straight up.
But you are now.
So now we're saying,
we have food deserts
where we're not getting
food to the right places.
But if we change
that in five years,
we may not be having that
same conversation anymore.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
special about now?
ROY CHOI: I think it's
a generational thing.
A lot of us are
going through it now.
So you hear all the comparisons
of it being like music.
Everyone is interested in food.
I think it's because
it's a human thing.
It's us.
We grew up.
I think it's the economy.
It's also a lot of the
things that you guys
are involved with, the
ability to share these things
immediately.
And then just from
our generation
some walls broken down to
where we are not-- our energies
aren't focused on
the same things
maybe previous generations are,
like exclusivity or just things
equating price with excellence.
And so I think all of
that converged together.
Also, just growing up.
Generations growing up.
People got smarter.
The chefs grew up.
The chefs actually trained.
So if you want to break it back
down to some specific things,
is we're a very young
eating culture in America.
This whole new wave started
about what, 15 years ago?
Because I remember when I was
in culinary school in '97, '98,
not that many people were
interested in the food
that they are now,
especially media.
And especially-- let's
just take even a microcosm
of that-- Asian.
Asian Americans.
They were not into food.
But now you go to
restaurants-- like I just
went to Bestia the other
night-- like fucking
80% of their dining
room were Asian kids,
like Asian American kids.
I was like, damn.
But when I was in
culinary school,
I was like one of the only
Asian dudes in culinary school.
Now I just went
back to CIA, it's
like half Asian
American kids there.
But that's just one
small microcosm.
I think the thing
is, what happened
is a lot of chefs in the
previous generation went out
to stage and to work in
Europe in different places.
And they came back
and work in kitchens.
And our whole--
obviously, we didn't
have social media and stuff.
The life of a cook
was very insular.
So we lived within, like,
a martial arts code.
So we trained under a chef,
whether it was in New York
or in Europe, and we
worked our way up,
and everything just
stay very inside.
But what happened was
it just all conversed.
It was a perfect storm.
A lot of these chefs,
they worked their stages.
It was time for
them to expand out.
Social media happened.
The ingredients start-- and
then the economy crashed.
You guys started making money.
You're young.
You wanted different things.
All those things came
together, and now we're here.
But now I think it's a
chance to-- since we're here,
and we're so interested by it,
it's a chance to really like
dissect it and take it
apart, and really look at,
has it changed?
Or are we just
another reflection
of a privileged society?
It's just cooler and funner.
Because there are
still the same people
that aren't getting food.
But I think it's
all those things.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What are
your thoughts on Yelp
and how chefs in L.A.
react to Yelp reviews?
ROY CHOI: Yelp reviews.
Yelp is a tough thing for me
because I'm a little older
and I don't get the
passive aggressive shit.
Like, I really don't get that.
I come from a generation-- an
O.G. Generation of you say what
you mean, or you
back up what you say.
The thing about Yelp
for me that's difficult
is how a lot of
the reviewers can't
stay upon one razor's edge.
Like, they say, you suck, but
I'll give you another chance,
but then I would never go back,
but if someone paid I would,
but only if they
paid all the way.
If I had to leave a
tip, I wouldn't go back.
But then if it was
a family member
and they were a little
down, then maybe I would.
And they always give like
one trap door after another.
So I think for me on
Yelp it's the trap doors.
Like, if the place
sucks, say it sucks.
And if you say you're
never going to go back,
fucking stand
behind those words.
But don't say you're never
going to go back and say
you would if someone
else would pay for it.
So for me, that's Yelp.
It's so fucking like--
I don't know, man.
It's a yellow streak.
It's just so cowardly.
But it's a great
resource as far as
like a soundbite for
people to look at something
and say, oh, here's a list.
As far chefs go, I can
only speak for myself,
but I feel like I
understand chef culture
in L.A. I don't look
at Yelp that much.
Because as much as that
is a wishy-washy kind
of environment, chefs
are the exact opposite.
We are like this is what
I'm cooking for you.
I think it's delicious.
And I hope you like it.
If you don't, tell me
why you don't like it,
and I may listen to
you or I may not.
So on for chef to read
Yelp and structure
their business or their
kitchen behind that-- man,
we would just pull our hair out.
Because I don't understand if
you like me or not, and that's
the biggest thing.
So we don't really
pay attention to it.
I think some of
the front of house
does, and uses it as
a model or as a marker
to see whether or not so they
need to make improvements
in their restaurants
or their facilities.
But most people on
the industry, they
look at Yelp over a period
of an average period.
So they'll take the
good with the bad,
and try to find is there
pattern or algorithm to it.
And then if there
is an algorithm,
maybe that is a truth.
So that's how we
feel about Yelp.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You partnered
earlier this year
with Three Worlds cafe to
serve in South Central.
Do you have plans
to expand out to
other underserved communities?
ROY CHOI: Yeah, I mean
I'm trying, definitely.
But I need help.
So I need help.
I need help in all aspects.
And I don't even want
to be the leader of it.
I just want to be a part of it.
I'm not doing it as a
crusade or anything.
I'm just doing it because
it's just a part of what I do.
It's the people I care about.
These are my friends
and neighbors.
But I'm doing everything
I can and trying
to-- but the thing is, we
need other chefs to do it
in their cities.
Again, we need to use some
of your guys' brainpower
to focus our energies to
figure out how we can just
get food a little
more accessible.
I think that's the first step.
We throw so much money
and so many resources--
let's take, for example,
skateboarding events,
or whatever.
We throw so much money
and fill their bodies
with energy drinks.
And these kids, they go back
home to fucking nothing.
And so it's really about just
shifting some of our priorities
and some of our energies
and our brainpower to like,
OK, let's continue to use this
marketing monster and animal,
but maybe figure out
a way to also make
food a little more
relative to culture.
So I need help on that end.
I need help as far as resources,
generating money and capital,
to get business owners
and companies to help
us build business
plans and programs that
aren't solely based upon profit.
That's a huge mountain to climb.
Everyone's going
this way, and I'm
telling everyone, go that way.
So I don't know.
I'm just starting.
I'm doing what I can.
Maybe in the next two
years, gather as many people
as I can together and
try to influence change,
but I can't stop now.
I woke up with it
a couple years ago.
When you read this
book, you see it's
been a part of my
life my whole life,
but this whole moment happened
to me on the anniversary
of the L.A. riots a
year and a half ago.
I woke up and I
was like fuck, man.
This shit is horrible.
It's horrible.
You guys have to relate
to this situation--
if you walk through south
central Los Angeles,
what you'll walk
through is not only
the disparity of
food and options,
but you also walk through an
educational system that is not
fostering advancement
and growth and learning.
So I was walking through it,
and I just woke up that day,
and I was just like,
this shit is horrible.
We're feeding them shit.
We're shoving them
in classrooms.
And we're not really
teaching them and giving them
the resources to
thrive and succeed.
So I was like, OK.
Let me do whatever little
I can do to at least try
to move that needle
over a little bit.
So ever since then, I've
just been doing that.
We started with the fruit.
Moved into a cafe.
Continue to use the truck
as a touchstone for the city
to connect to.
I spoke about it in Copenhagen,
and I'm also now trying
to use whatever resources
I have through this book,
and also through whatever
agency I'm affiliated with
to try to get foundations going.
Big thing, long
story short, is I'm
going to try to start
my own nonprofit now.
So that was the biggest
revelation for me
over the last six months was
I thought that you could only
start a nonprofit
if you were a rich.
But I found out that you
can start it any time.
I really didn't know that shit.
I really didn't know.
I thought it was this arc.
Like you had to get
really, really rich,
and then you start a nonprofit.
I found you could start
at any time in life,
so I'm going to start one.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: After Kogi
started really happening,
it seemed like all the
restaurants and trucks
in L.A. were sort of
Korean. [INAUDIBLE]
spark a trend, or [INAUDIBLE]?
ROY CHOI: That question as
a few facets to the answer.
A lot of people only write
about the gourmet food truck
movement, but what it did-- not
only did it feed the streets
and create great eating options
for yourselves at lunch--
and you can just
see if you go over
by your old offices on
26th and Pennsylvania
over there, Santa Monica.
But it also created a whole
wave of entrepreneurs,
young entrepreneurs.
Back four years ago,
I read about it,
but like Kogi opened up kind
of a spiritual gateway for me.
I could almost feel it,
almost like in a movie.
Like I just imagined people just
getting up out of their cubicle
and walking the fuck
out of the office
and then starting
a waffle truck.
And that happened in multitudes
in every city across America.
And so I'm really proud
that, five years later,
I close my eyes and imagine how
many people out there started
a whole new life
because of this.
I mean, there's got
be like thousands.
Thousands of new lives that
have been created where they're
out there right now in
Seattle serving food, and four
years ago they were miserable.
And they're having the time
of their life right now.
I'm really, really
happy about that.
As far as the actual duplicate
of the taco-- it's weird, man.
Everyone's had every-- it's
almost like-- I went out there.
I put everything
out there, naked.
Like every recipe of Kogi is
out there in the universe,
but in five years, no one's
been able to replicate it.
And I think because Kogi
is not just the food.
It's something else.
I mean, you guys understand.
You work for a company
that represents that.
It's something else.
It's not one thing.
It's everything.
You are a part of Kogi.
I'm a part of Kogi.
My team members, the
food, the flavor.
But also the street,
the environment.
The chase.
The Twitter.
The connection.
The conversations that happen
in line, sitting on the corner.
All those things.
The culture.
You can't just replicate that.
It is its own beast.
And I think that's why no
one's been able to do it.
Also, the food is very personal.
You have the recipe for
salsa verde or whatever,
but the Kogi taco
itself is actually
like a piece of my skin.
It's like a fingerprint.
It's just an expression of
what I went through in life.
And the style of Kogi
itself-- that's the food.
The style of Kogi
is a fingerprint
of our team members,
of who we are.
I feel like if anyone
could have copied it,
they should have been able
to figure it out by now,
and they haven't.
So I'm cool with that.
I'm not even mad.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think what makes
your food great is it's just
a fusion of a lot of
different parts of L.A.
and just parts of different
cultures without explicitly
being fusion, like
combining these two cultures
and just combining
what tastes good.
Like Chago, which
will severely be
missed on the West Side is an
expression of that, I think.
When you come up
with new recipes,
do you play to what you're
familiar with, with Korean
and Mexican street
food in L.A., or do you
explore other-- use
other tastes to try
to combine them into recipes?
Is it an exploration
or more what just--
ROY CHOI: I'm in a very
fortunate place right now,
and I don't take
anything for granted as
far as creative development.
Man, like what happened
to me five years ago,
it unlocked something in me.
So now the whole universe
is up for grabs for me.
So it's like a DJ now for me.
I just, I pull and take
anything I can or want.
And so I'm not trying to
adhere to any authenticity
to anything.
I just have a goal
of making food that's
delicious and as
powerful as possible.
I just follow my gut on things.
Like, if I had a
plan for anything,
I would've rode the Kogi wave
and been the next Chipotle,
or whatever.
But everything I've opened
since then have been different.
Because they've just
been like these--
you'll read it
when you guys read
this book-- these
wake up moments.
Just wake up, like, sunny spot.
Wake up and go, shit.
I want to cook Jamaican food.
And so it's just like I
go off on that tangent.
And then when I go off on
that tangent, what I do
is I just open up all my
senses and everything.
I try to pull in
everything about what
it means to cook Caribbean food.
Not just the cooking part of
it, but the culture, the music,
the people, the history, the
pain, the struggle, the joys,
all that stuff.
I try to pull that in the food.
And I think that's the flavor
of what we try to cook.
That's why you can't pinpoint
where does it become Korean
or where does it become Mexican.
Because there is no
pinpoint to that.
It actually represents
Los Angeles.
So it's like,
traveling from here,
if we take Venice Bo--
I'll end it like this.
I like to equate it, like,
if you take Venice Boulevard
down-- if you start here
and you end up down at Pico
Union on Venice-- where
can you really pinpoint
where it changes?
You can see it change, but
it's all still Los Angeles.
It all represents Los Angeles.
And I think that's what
my food is right now.